[Music]
date December 24th 2018 warning breach
in progress please remain in place
annual recovery plan is to be executed
Jacob heard a loud thump on the roof
above him he peeked out from under the
covers of his racecar bed
despite about night light beside the bed
cast a warm white glow that illuminated
the room his clock on the night table
beside him read 6:44 a.m. jacob
stretched and yawned and stepped out of
bed his spongebob pajamas reached down
to his ankles and he put on a pair of
brown slippers with a dog's face and
floppy dog ears on the sides
he opened his door just a crack and
looked out into the hallway
the noise above him had stopped but he
was too excited to care he stepped out
of his room softly and looked down over
the railing at the Christmas tree in the
corner of the living room beside the big
front window the lights of the tree
reflected off the myriad of shiny balls
and baubles that hung on the trees
branches just then a man in a red coat
came walking out of the chimney oddly
this wasn't a man-sized chimney and this
was no normal sized man
the jolly fat man passed through the
brick of the fireplace like it wasn't
there behind him a trail of little
bright lights illuminated the space he
passed through he had no bag unlike what
Jacob had expected but began to make his
way to the Christmas tree all the same
the man reached a hand out and more of
the bright light appeared in the air
beside him he reached into the hole and
pulled out a beautifully wrapped present
Jacob beside himself with excitement
that had a small gasp the man in red
stopped and looked up he spotted Jacob
and gave him a cheeky grin the redness
in his cheeks increasing just a bit
come down here the man in red called out
in a loud whisper Jacob hurried down the
stairs as softly as he could by the time
he made it to the tree the man in red
had already pulled another gift out of
thin air you've been very good this year
haven't you Jacob Jacob nodded don't
tell your mom and dad and I'll let you
open this one right now
Jacob's eyes brightened even more in the
light of the Christmas tree he reached
forward and took the box pulling on the
bow and ripping off the paper inside was
a stuffed animal in the shape of a puppy
with big brown eyes and the curly tail
Jacob hugged it close and looked back up
at the man in red now I know you asked
for a real dog but your mother was right
the man in red squinted at the boy
you're still too young to take care of
one I hope this little guy will be
enough until you grow up big and strong
[Applause]
Jacob got it even more forcefully and
hugged the stuffed doll even closer the
man in red winked with a slight twinkle
in his eye before the color in his
cheeks began to fade the two of them
looked out the large bay window next to
the tree and just the slightest hint of
sunlight was peeking out from above the
horizon
Jacob looked back at the old man next to
the Christmas tree the old man smiled at
Jacob and cocked his head to the side
the same twinkle in his eye as before
Jakob's eyes went wide again and then
suddenly the floor dropped out from
underneath him he was sinking through
something sticky that burned him the old
man now skinny and with blackened skin
leaned in with an impossibly wide smile
it's the day after scp-106 is annual
breach the standard recovery protocol
was executed scp-106 his transformation
lasted approximately 13 hours in 25
minutes this time during its
transformation visited 1067 homes ball
in the end of the entity's
transformation it was responsible for
the death or disappearance of three
individuals aged thirty eight thirty
four and seven no foundation personnel
were lost during the recovery recovery
evaluation successful I would like to
give a special thank you to all the time
gaming Zach Geller
James Saba Katherine Jews Jax Marek
Pablo ice 917 Burlington the cat Karim
Allah schmoovy Justin de Pury kuma
Reilly Sean Murphy
Traver W peg white crew Nicholas James
vu Jack Bryson Bailey my archive curator
neck tie verbal Alex Gil Dre rook the
Android Jacob Ganim pity quartz 5 6 3 &
tree here if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos and some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
you